tu peux lui pourquoi ton chat sur mon
livre que tu viens jamais je vais
filetta chambre d'accord
deux ans et demi deux ans qui me trompes
tu te rends compte du parti illico va
bien s'est il m'est a dit quoi la
bourgeoise à 10 mois tour par ville
parce que c'est aussi d'avoir un peu de
cave et après tu te demandes pourquoi
pas plus souvent
vous verrez pas venir danser avec nous
non je te remercie je crois que j'ai eu
mon quota de ridicule ces derniers temps
les prochaines actions du club rien
n'est pas dsk donnant à t-elle pas les
vieux pas pourquoi ça sera pas dans le
doute
c'est cool que soit venu je serais
restée compliquée entre vous compliqué
c'est pire que ça on essaiera
faux plis du temps où ton moi
j'adorerais pouvoir tout reprendre à
zéro et pas roberto qu'est-ce que tu
ferais bien un jour je navigue vers la
hollande
serais tu voulais pas danser en public
ouais
sur beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait 20 ans que le bâtiment n'est
plus aux normes il faut que vous
acceptiez de partir alors ce sera
l'expulsion les aime bien tous ces gens
pourtant mais j'ai pas le choix on a
toujours le choix bon alors on fait quoi
elle a perdu parce que j petit bras
[Musique]
la vie est courte n'est jamais trop tard
pour en profiter
toute une vie de travail détruit le
à 2,3
[Musique]